[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video i've got some very
exciting news regarding the third and
upcoming installment of the fantastic
beasts film franchise fantastic beasts
three we haven't had a fantastic beast
film in a long time as the first
installment fantastic beasts and where
to find them was released in 2016 and
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald was released in 2018. it's
now the end of 2021 so you might be
wondering ok where is this thing the
film was originally scheduled for
november 2020 but was postponed due to
the need for a screenplay rewrite this
pushed the film back to november 2021
but then disaster struck in the form of
a pandemic and the film was postponed
again the new release date being july
2022 being pushed back even further so
with all of that said you might be glad
to hear that fantastic beast 3 is
actually ahead of schedule and is now
going to be released during easter of
the new release date of april 15th moved
up from july 15th is already getting
fans excited and as it turns out warner
bros had actually held the easter
weekend release quite a while ago for an
untitled movie guess we lucked out there
this brings us to my next point what is
the name of this film the end of the
second film left us on a massive
cliffhanger with grindelwald revealing
his heritage to credence there is legend
in your family that a phoenix will come
to any member who's in dire need it is
your birthright my boy as is the name i
now restore to you aurelius dumbledore
though grindelwald doesn't confirm who
exactly aurelius's parents are he does
refer to albus as the young man's
brother so we can safely assume that he
belongs to at least one of alba's
parents albus was the eldest son in the
dumbledore family and his parents were
percival and kendra dumbledore before
this point in time it was widely thought
there were only three dumbledore
children albus aberforth and ariana but
with all of that said if aurelius is a
dumbledore it's actually very unlikely
he's the son of both kendra and percival
percival was in azkaban from 1890 onward
and there is no way that they could have
conceived a child there however there is
always the possibility that kendra had a
child with another man while percival
was imprisoned this child regardless of
the father would be albus's half-brother
if she gave birth in 1898 a year before
she died then credence would be 27 28 in
the films that we've seen so far
kendra's shame might also explain why
baby aurelius was on a ship bound for
america so what's the deal well the new
title certainly touches on this and
could potentially reveal all the new
title fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore may shine light on the
dumbledore family and expose them in a
way that we've never seen before i made
some speculations in the past on what
the title for this film might be and i
said the loss to dumbledore so i guess
it wasn't too far off are you guys
excited for this what do you think these
secrets are comment down below i'll be
covering more related to this film in
the coming weeks until next time
remember youth cannot know how age
thinks and feels but old men are guilty
if they forget what it was to be young